this video was advertised by candy crush
hi everyone
i'm pumped because this podcast is
sponsored by candy crush all stars
america's first candy crush tournament
you know candy crush is my is my
favorite game i play it i've been
playing it in this tournament i've been
playing it for weeks
it's not as glamorous as in this
beautiful studio and wearing dresses
that have candy all over them i usually
play it in gate b9 but today i get to
play it with my friends and the good for
you team it's the game that i play on
the road when i don't want to text my
exes but i need something to do to
distract myself from my own inner
monologue thank you candy crush and the
candy crush all-star tournament it's
free to play anyone can join so many
people are currently playing now the
tournament is already in full flow we
are the first of two wild card rounds
you've seen mr bobby lee and andrew
santino playing why did bobby lee get a
mister and santino didn't i think he
said mrs bobby lee
i think you misread that i love bobby
lee
you uh santino and bobby lee just did it
um but let's be honest they're not a
threat to us absolutely um bobby you've
seen his body he eats too much candy
um
i get out candy crush them in my sleep
uh if you haven't yet hit the link in
the description and start playing candy
crush all stars in the tournament now
we're go we're reading some stuff
verbatim
just so we don't mess it up and get sued
right but we are going to play candy
crush with you guys for the next hour
willis talking about our own
crushes yes
as in sexual crushes
hold on everyone's playing candy crush
right now and i'm feeling ignored i
haven't even started we're all playing
while we talk and whoever has the
highest score at the end is the winner
whoever is the lowest score has to eat
the most horrifying disgusting jelly
beans while we are doing game play
playing our favorite game you guys
should all join the tournament so come
play with us the uh tournament is free
to enter you just need to be on level 26
to compete the final winner will receive
a year's supply of gold bars to use in
the game enter the all-stars competition
for a chance to win okay so our favorite
thing to do in this office is to compete
with each other and pit each other
against each other so you're about to
see
four very type a people turn on each
other it's like succession with no money
succession with no money it's like
succession but um no love so the end the
consequences whoever loses this has to
eat these jelly beans i know that
doesn't sound like a big punishment but
these jelly belly bamboozled jelly beans
they got me and they got me good last
year so they what they do is they took a
whole year
they do
jelly beans that look the same so the
white ones for example are going to be
coconut or
spoiled milk
the ones that are white with little dots
are going to be birthday cake delicious
or dirty dishwasher
the ones that look like toasted
marshmallow will be toasted marshmallow
or
stink bug no stink bug is don't smell it
whitney eat really
you can't smell them before you buy them
ruined christmas for me
and then there's one that is tutti
frutti but there's a charlatan bean
that's stinky socks that one's good too
really bad i like two fruits no juicy
pear which is my favorite jelly belly
the other one is a booger
that one's just salty huh that was just
kind of salty okay you're kind of salty
i know let me play our game what are
these glasses you're wearing these are
my candy crush grasses he made them your
what's your my candy crush glasses not
everybody had and i already had a gown
fitted for them okay benton also
we are wearing our candy crush um
dresses i don't know if you guys have
seen i'm on the front of whitney's we're
now in the lollipop guild this is me as
a baby
burping
this is me pregnant just a smiley face
okay so we're wearing our candy crush
dresses and we want to make it a little
more interesting so while we are playing
we are drinking a drink bent and made
that's been roofied i can't drink it
because of my acid reflux um i have
gerds
fun
um but to make it more interesting while
we talk about our crushes whoever is
playing and gets the color bomb
which is right here it looks like a
chocolate
it looks like a chocolate it's on
emily's inverted nipple um
a chocolate ball with covered sprinkles
whoever gets that while they're playing
gets to call out someone else at the
table and they have to share their
embarrassing crush because we spend a
lot of time in the show talking about
the things we don't like right but let's
talk about the things we do like because
that's embarrassing we have crushes on
who we like we know we're watching let's
get cancelled let's bring some bridges
all right dorks um are we ready yes yeah
let's go ready ready hold on we're going
to start playing candy crush the first
roll of candy crush is crush crush okay
ready ready and go go okay oh guess what
i got a chocolate color ball okay i got
a color bomb no you
you i pick you okay rude oh i got
another one okay um okay calm down okay
my first crush i have a crush on tom
hardy
and
right mad max himself he is the hottest
to me
but here's why
well first of all his lips are very
pillowy and uh
i'm just my type physically is a guy
that looks like he just got punched in
the face in a bar fight and the swelling
hasn't gone down yet that's my kink okay
but the main thing for me a lot of
people don't think about this they think
actors are really hot really sexy then
you see them on the red carpet posing
and you're like
why can't i get sexual attraction
conjured up for this person right right
guys posing for a photo there's just
something
he brings
pitbulls on the red carpet look google
tom
hardy
uh red carpet he brings rescue pitbulls
that need homes and you know that's the
way to my heart
anyone that can love a mutt can love me
yeah if you guys if you can love a
rescue pitbull we're gonna get along
just fine i thought you were gonna say
your crush was clifford clifford the big
red dog
the dog from marley and me
too
too soon
snoopy spoiler oh my god the target dog
i feel like there's there's that's gonna
go all day such a bummer lassie david
bowie labyrinth you know is my number
one number one sure oh yeah he looks
like me my you know what honestly if i
have a crush on david bowie from
labyrinth i'm also in love with you
emily there's i can't have it both ways
you would fall in love with someone who
has a mullet and makes babies disappear
this is why you're always going to
planned parenthood's in the south huh
your other cake i mean look he was he
was he had like a hundred baby gremlins
like that is that is the father figure
yeah that's responsible but he made them
the only thing better than the goblins
the other the only thing better than a
guy with a kid the only thing that's
hotter is one that's like i'm gonna keep
them babies forever like i want to care
take babies forever really don't you
think this is why you're in hollywood
you're like what's harder than men who
love babies
um i don't know it's weird though when
you look back on it he was 36 and he was
i think she was 16 at the time they were
doing that
not great not ideal but i loved at the
end that he like the things he would say
he would just be like um
everything i do i do for you like i like
that like toxic codependent stuff she's
like you remind me of the babe she's
like i am a babe
remind me because i she's like
no but it's like everything i do i do
for you
that's hot when you're younger when you
get older when someone says that it's
like sounds like you don't have a job
she's like do my homework then i'm in
school
can you do trigonometry
yeah okay i want i want you blondarella
you tell us
i'm assuming you're speaking to me emily
i was blonde yesterday that's it's true
we ought to keep up uh who am i crushes
yeah okay first one
basic
be that i am is someone everyone expects
me to have a crush on hold on let me
guess go ahead
not pit no
yes but like um like yeah you're very
you like you're shallow oh we just got
we discovered the monopoly man because
when you pass go you collect 200 bucks
and that's very good no i'm a shallow
i'm not a gold digger she's you're
actually not that shallow remember we
got rear ended by that male model that
had an english accent and you didn't
even flirt with anything well she
couldn't see him because of all the
tears and he came out in his towel he
had been at the beach
wait yeah okay you guys have been
withholding that piece of information
from me emily got in a car accident on
topanga yeah i show up
thank god i had put some like ck1 on in
the car but wait let me tell the story
cause i'll okay so i
people like to mother me i was crying
hysterically on the side of the road
i've been rear-ended that is an
understatement people like to mother you
been rear-ended yeah who we don't enjoy
doing this been rear-ended not my fault
this time i'm crying hysterically i call
whitney i'm like i can't come to work
because um i got rear-ended and
whitney's like don't apologize i know
you're gonna apologize and if you're not
at fault then you're gonna get in
trouble and she's like i bet this guy's
a a jerk and didn't like being so like
mama bear i was like put your voice
memos on record everything that he said
he's gonna out he's out to get you like
don't let it happen she gets there she
sees them she's like maybe you were
driving a little slowly
it's a um
pierce model pierce brosnan
full sean connery from the 70s with the
british british accent he's a english
male model he he bottles for like brooke
burke's brother yeah yeah something we
looked at whitney was so distracted
hit me while she was going to help emily
she like almost ran into me with her car
what are you doing she was looking at
that was looking at this man and then
she was so cons he was so concerned
about you that made him even hotter i
know is she okay is she okay i feel so
bad for i'm like she's mentally ill
you'd be concerned too if there were
eight people that surrounded him all of
a sudden like what say to the phone and
i was like i've got this handle sir what
is your phone number give me your direct
phone number how do you handle this
personally what is your number sir and
he kept saying do you want a taco
taco stand right by in topanga at a taco
see you to taco and i was like i don't
wanna talk about that's flirting do you
want a taco sir
i already have one
uh
wait
so
hold on i are are people playing yeah
i'm like i feel like you're trying to
distract me i feel like you're telling
stories because i want to win oh okay so
my crush is chris evans captain america
yeah captain america
yeah and i think that we would do well
together so you you just want someone
that requires a lot of sunscreen he's
hot and he's kind you know what i mean
it's like
there's such a thing as too handsome
but he used to be too handsome if you
look at older pictures he's not that as
handsome as he is now so he got surgery
it's a hot tub so she's like remember
when he was gross he was okay here's my
what do you mean he wasn't hot before he
was you mean when he was a child yeah
like early you know he's gotten hotter
as he's gotten older he's gonna hear
this other other things he dated jenny
slate i love jeff oh that's right i can
i tell you something when i find out a
guy is dating a girl that i love it
makes me like yeah yeah yes that's what
i'm saying i would love to be
you know involved with someone that was
involved with jenny slate because i just
love her and then also
um it feels like a road map to being a
lesbian okay okay but it it's a little
on the nose
is here brad pitt hot take
i think
okay if chris evans were not famous and
if john mayer were not famous if they
were just
regular people civilians right i bet i
could hook up with one of them
interesting okay what's your opening
line where would you be
what do you mean where would i be
where's she always she's always like on
the beach would they be at your parents
house like where are you going to meet
them but no no what's your opening line
well i don't have i don't have an
opening line you know what you are
you're a straight white guy
you're the guy who's like i bet i could
i could i could date her like if she
wasn't on this
super girl if she wasn't on the cw like
i'd have a shot at her totally you're a
straight guy totally you like but but
that's not we're talking about our
crushes we're not talking about i have a
correction but the idea of a crush is
that it's the point is they're out of
your league okay and you're like just
fyi they're in my life really yeah
you're talking about a hall pass no no
here's what i'm saying i have reasonable
expectations if i were a teenager in the
60s guess who my beetle would have been
ringo no one wanted him
you think that chris evans has a
reasonable expectation
if he weren't famous
but also
guys that aren't famous you wouldn't
have the crowd
yeah they
you'd be like we're talking about two
different things i we're talking about
two different things i think that were
chris evans a civilian
i could at least he's captain i can't i
can't i could let me just be clear he's
the main civilian he's catching him
everyone calm down
you guys something revolutionary just
happened which is that it turns out
emily does have self-esteem and
i would like for you to bring this into
your work uh
environment and go like
you know when you uh when i try to um
when you thank me for something and i
say you're welcome and you're like are
you gonna fire me can we like maybe
bring the
the uh i could totally date chris evans
if he was a civilian energy into your
work
yeah we could try we could we could try
yeah yeah we could try like when i try
to pay you your paycheck which you
earned and then you won't take it
because you're like i don't know what
you think i'm stealing from you like
what that's cause i am stealing from you
twice the same person that goes out in
the world is like i could i could land
chris evans i could with this
personality you're so funny i could
especially now with my gerds i'm going
to lose so much weight
so yeah he likes them skinny and burpee
no he's a butt man uh gerds he's gone on
the record he's a very high stakes uh
candy crush tournament game going
because she cannot have one of these uh
disgusting jelly belly jelly beans um
that will hoodwink her because she's got
girts and she will actually um combust
remember in childhood chocolate factory
who's the girl that
that wanted the golden ticket so bad and
she blew into blueberry
yeah that's violet violet you're turning
it
mine
okay well i've always loved the nanny
because i love a woman in clashing
patterns and a shrill voice absolutely
i'm gonna say hey mama
i feel like your vision board was all
fran joshua from the nanny and like
whatever like mercury and retrograde or
whoever like conflated it was like
whitney come here
i was like she's the nanny
obviously megan fox oh yeah i mean i
love someone who's so hot that the world
has to be like butter thumbs
could you imagine being so hot that
people have to be like put your fingers
what is that because she they people she
just has like round thumbs and people
are just like oh i also love the idea
it's not that your thumbs it's just
it's just compared to all thumbs are
ugly yeah just compared to your face but
imagine you can't trust me imagine being
so hot that the world is like ooh your
thumb like that's all they have you have
to find some kind yeah you have to and
then i love men that'll like when you
when you bring up megan fox
there'll be certain guys that'll be like
she's not that hot i was like you're not
in the running you're not in the right
way
those are my people that's what emily
just did she's like the guys are like
you stop tearing down you loser like
you're not an option i know i like that
guys like look at tv shows as like as if
it's tinder yeah and they're swiping
left like they're like she's not that
hot
yeah okay okay is that the story we're
gonna go with that's why you're not
dating is that why you're not together
you rejected her i don't even see
rihanna
also i had elvira a virus a big crush of
mine you know
funny hot in a costume but talk to me
about elvira what how how is elvira not
given more
credit isn't the word but alvirah made
it when she was like 50 as a sex symbol
i mean novara's been she's been going
and going elvira is 2b
stand so hard this is like the original
girl she's an alter ego too her name's
cassandra she's a redhead that is
fascinating to me at first she made just
300 a week as alvira now she makes more
than a million dollars a year
there have been more than 400 licensed
elvira queen of merch what was your
favorite halloween candy
my favorite halloween candy your
favorite halloween greece's pumpkins
wow that's a good one
what'd you think i was gonna say candy
corn i don't know i wonder if elvira is
playing in this amazing tournament
interesting segway you would like to
join you should click the link in the
bio and you can compete against us
and i'm killing it right now are you how
are you doing i'm i like the one i like
that my favorite part of the um candy
crush is when it gets the icing when you
break the icing oh yeah
crush and it's making us not finish our
sentences you should have been allowed
to play by your assistant what's that
but why is why is it so satisfying to do
this and when the phone jiggle like i
love you so good as someone i did make a
movie about neuroscience i wish i had
included something about why it's so
satisfying to
like crush candies i love it when the
frosting explodes i love it when i make
one swipe being like i guess this is
probably a move and that it just does
the whole thing for me
i love it okay can you please uh uh
whoever has the newest um chocolate
sprinkle ball
you have to someone has to say they're
crushed because i've been talking too
much now i'm behind and i'm going to
lose and i don't want to eat a stinky
sock jelly bean okay i can't
obviously my crush is the hollywood
nepotism queen herself dakota johnson
oh she is she is twitter in human form
just walking around like be accountable
you're accountable yes she says i detect
a lie
i feel like she doesn't do it on purpose
it's not no she's just like nobody can
tell me
anything
you realize dakota johnson
is a person that was sprung from melanie
griffith who was sprung from a one tippy
hedgerow
who lived with lions right yeah do you
understand that tippy hedren when tippy
was raising tippy hatchin famous actress
from the uh alfred hitchcock's hitchcock
movies i know her because we used to
audition together back in the 20s um
well let me tell you something you
better tip your toe around dakota
johnson because she will
there's like four or five people that i
would not get in a ring oh yeah no no
she's one of them
her birthday was her birthday was the
other day you know what she did she took
down instagram for nine hours then did
you know the instagram celebrated her on
her birthday there's like a whole group
of people that were like uh who's
celebrating dakota johnson's birthday
today yeah as they should also gorgeous
she's allergic to lions
no but but she's allergic to she noted
she's allergic to
she invented bangs people think people
think it was zoey deschanel but it was
dakota johnson she did it
for a second i thought it was rasheeda
jones and you're like wait no wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait it's dakota
banks those like choppy choppy bangs in
such a cute effortless way icon legend
star icon legend star an icon legend and
a star
born into it born
into it but er earned it
i think she would have made it anyway
one of my favorite things about dakota
johnson is that she does such a wide
variety of movies she also did that
movie uh with um casey affleck and uh
what's his face um seth rogen where like
one of them is not she's dying oh that's
sad yeah the red range the rain wait
what's the horror movie again
that's such a good movie such a good
movie do we think dakota johnson is
playing the candy crush tournament
dakota johnson's candy crushing it
a hundred percent
if you haven't yet if you haven't yet
join me now go run crush this podcast is
sponsored by candy crush all stars we're
playing you should too the candy crush
all-star tournament is so much fun look
at us we are eating candy we are playing
candy crush we are talking about our
crushes i'm gonna have to eat some
disgusting jelly beans very soon i'm
ruining a lot of relationships with a
lot of people i am burning bridges so
get involved the candy crush all stars
tournament is so much fun everyone can
enter anyone can win and it is free to
play click the link in the description
to start playing now and play for your
chance to win a year's supply of gold
bars
yes i said a year's supply if you
haven't started yet join in on the fun
now to beat the competition the candy
crush all-star tournament is so much fun
you know i'm the best but go ahead keep
playing try to beat me i dare you
i feel like i'm talking a lot of hui uh
that i can't back up because i've mostly
been talking about crushes and
critiquing yells instead of actually
playing what is your favorite candy my
favorite number one halloween candy if
you're if you're trick-or-treating
treaters are coming what are you doing
in the basket halloween candies
obviously reese's pumpkin but just candy
in general i love a payday um totally
nuts for all people
wow that's really hard really very
interesting for that either i love pay
days they're delicious what's the payday
payday it's never heard of a payday i
have not
us we're in the sweetest elevator of all
time candy crush music this is like how
dancing with the star song start
um
that is
uh
payday or zero bar that goes well that
that's the category of like mounds okay
you're being a pygmy girl with these no
that's like in the south people like
those candy bars are you going to say
snickers
no but
yeah i am you're more like a friend
a bar person i i do a three
musketeers for years and years of my
life i have things you must get here
were diet candy bars i mean i went gears
being like these are diet candy bars
because of the commercials
my i'm a ride or die reece's peanut
butter cups
it's not candy yeah that's a confection
hard candy favorite like hard candy i
need that kind of
candy well that's easy like does sour
skittles count
oh yeah that's a good one peach rings
count yeah i love pea trees yeah
i love those strawberries that are hard
and soft in the middle like grandma's
have yeah we got the strawberry and you
have to understand the haribo coca-cola
bottles
those are good
like you take the colorful little shorts
yes yes yes not like dot stuff with
nothing
wafers oh no no okay y'all are no
no no these are all the like oh let me
guess what's next charleston chew
what is that no i don't know charleston
chew that's like taffy it sounds like a
dancer cocktails i love do you cow tails
cadbury cream eggs
cream eggs are delicious how is that a
candy and not a reese's peanut butter
cup well i'm just trying to get an
understanding of where our candy yes
because i have a lot widely there's
candy bars and there's candy that's true
right i am going to say something that
is going to ruin all of our you have a
crush on willy wonka
oh obviously you are only one cut this
hair is 100
you are wrong the only other person i
have met on this earth
that loves candy corn is my
eight-year-old niece and it is something
that i've had to work through with her
like i love her delicious so much pure
sugar
what about the pumpkins do you eat the
candy corn no
they're so intense yeah are you a pee
person not a pee person oh i'm a peep
gal but only the tail only the tail the
hard there's no difference it's all the
things that's just you're eating a
marshmallow right you're getting more
greasy covered in sugar it's gross okay
you're i'm sorry you like dots you like
eating off of a piece of paper no wonder
you're burping those are good yeah paper
plates you want to eat like a receipt
with a bunch of little dribbles of sugar
delicious you once eat a an apple
wrapped in cellophane yes i did but i
was on amazon
i was on ambien
okay do caramel apples count as candy
because that that is that is so good
obsessed with that
lollipops oh yeah
there's something you get it you have
one
two of those in your halloween bag i am
as obsessed with caramel candy apples as
i am with playing candy crush and this
tournament is so much fun i love caramel
apples i love caramel apples almost
because i love this game yes this
tournament is so fun and when i win you
all have to make me caramel apples emily
what is your favorite candy bar in your
favorite candy see i have never i it
really takes a virgo to come in and
compartmentalize the candy world
we're already talking about our favorite
candies can you not bring a fake science
into it this is nothing with me being a
virgo
i just have never had such strict
parameters and talking about
different kinds of candy everyone knows
i don't
because i got another one of the um
yummy balls i have a crush on the king
of the swamp himself
mr shrek
human or ogre shrek
i could see them all both i don't like
it it's about the personality it's not
about it's not about the shell it's
about it's about the person inside
yes the
what's your favorite onion red onions
purple onions
i like pickled red onions that's my
favorite food actually vidalia wow yeah
um i can totally see the shrek thing yes
and and shrek would love candy crush
because all these green squares the
thing with shrek is that he is
shark's favorite candy will be cotton
candy
say more about that yeah defend yourself
it's just like that's here's the thing
you will interrupt someone to say
something and then not defend it at all
you need to start showing up for
yourself and defend yourself i can't
show for myself i thought you can't
handle the truth you don't get to just
say something that makes absolutely no
sense when someone is making i'm sorry
let's talk more about ogres and how that
makes sense i'm sorry can we get back to
your crush on cartoons i hate that i
interrupted that he's so far offline you
would never be able to stalk him you
would never be able to stock any of his
exes he'd just be like yeah i used to do
i used to like live with this girl just
like never know yeah just watch the
movie that would drive me crazy yeah but
it's for the best ultimately but
wouldn't you be bummed that you're so
much tinier than all his exes
no that's a perk
for a ogre it might not be you might
just be too tiny okay but in this
scenario when my head shrek is obsessed
with me yeah
i like he's very burly he's very yeah he
has a wood chopping body which is
famously the hottest body that is hot
you know what is the high spot i am with
you but what is what's truck's wife's
name
fiona i like her too though yeah i do
like her i'm willing to get in the
middle of that oh that is you're the
dragon in track aggressive
me yeah no i'm like because she's like
obsessed with the donkey what is another
one of your crushes because you've only
said chris evans it's very basic it's
very basic okay i'm shooting my shot
with this one because this
is possibly attainable
are you going to say that but but
crushes aren't supposed to be attainable
it's supposed to be like like no i'm
using my format okay okay does that mean
use your
and i hit my throat on my microphone
okay here's does anyone watch
summer house
it's a reality television show
and there is a girl on it and she played
for you has a boyfriend
and i have a crush on that boyfriend his
name is robert he's a chef is it this
which one no
he
your crush has a girlfriend and he's not
in the castle which guy that looks like
a nazi is he he's not in the cast he's a
friend of the gap oh oh
this is your body pillow because i tried
to look this man up and i could not find
anything i was gonna say the only thing
that came up were linkedin
your crush shouldn't have to be two
googles away can you just say someone we
all know
can i not mess up my algorithm
trying to find your crush
like what does that mean it just why
what about him what about him i just
he's just he's he's a chef
he has a whole leg tattoo he's just hot
you thought i've never made out with
anyone with a tattoo are you really
serious never wow mm-hmm oh i have
i haven't
that's a lie
why you're lying to be honest with you
we are playing candy crush in this
tournament we are playing candy crush i
am playing for you because i am losing
so i am benched because i am horrified
by the types of i now we talk about red
flags on this podcast a lot maybe we
need to do like red
hot flags or what are they called green
flags like just something
asking someone's favorite candy really
tells you a lot about who they are
really and asking someone's crush asking
someone's favorite candy and their crush
might be a new way to
hire people do you think any just
somebody else playing this tournament is
this hostile
i really think anyone else is arguing
this much during candy
like this is like a joyful game people
are in a tournament competing and we're
over here like
but i think the problem is we're all
trying to lose because the quote
punishment is eating candy
that's true and i know which bean is
actually good okay so here are a couple
more of my crushes okay yeah nobody
watched my so-called life oh no jordan
catalano i'm 10 years old that is my
main
whitney i am right there with you but it
wasn't
him per se it was jordan it was jordan
not do not conflate jared leto with
jordan catalano jared leto you are seem
like a lovely person right your band
mars bars what happened to those
can you believe people that are like oh
i want a mound
mounds bar i don't know okay here's the
thing about mountains bars is mounds
bars were too early so i do have time
they were ahead of their time now people
are all into coconut now because it's
like healthy coconut
was not in in the 80s and 90s when
mounds they were ahead of their time but
why wouldn't you want the almond why
wouldn't you why don't you choose a
mound over an almond joy
wait what's in the almond joy almond joy
is the same thing as a man plus an
almond
it's just marketing baby yeah
remarketing baby
so many almond joys one time that i
could never eat them again
do you remember reasons no reason
chocolate caramels i've never heard of
chocolate oh but i do just love a good
caramel you have deep cuts for candy i
have not heard of a lot of these i was
raised on candy you guys this is this is
where i should actually
and they have a roland mcflurry they
have them at like 10 locations across
the country
that is better than winning the lottery
oh well yeah because the ice cream
machine has to work but here's the thing
about rolos is they knew how good this
is how good rollers were this is how
good they knew they were they
individually wrapped every bite and knew
you would do the work
and you i would drool while i was like
you're as you're chewing one you're
unwrapping that
yeah yeah and i have drool running down
my treats being like i can't wait to
roll those are so good you eat them
alone they're so good they're like i'm
not sharing you would just eat them
alone like
eating rolo wrapping paper yeah yeah
yeah like absolutely you need a lot of
paper
um remember uh
oh these strawberry candies that you
would get in doctor's offices these are
like oh i do like those in my house
right now they're in like bowls
everywhere are you a grandma coming over
it had like a strawberry on the outside
and the top of the wrapping and it was
wet leaves wet in the middle right
remember um uh gum with goo in the
middle what was that called
the gum
did you uh how about the juicy stuff yes
there was like goo inside yeah in the
gum yes there was zebra gum remember
zebra gum or bubble shape remember fruit
stripe gum with the tattoo but there was
gum where you would chew it and like goo
would come out
i love it do you remember the baseball
gum that looked like dip
i
remember gatorade made gum for a minute
it was bubble yum oh bubble yum yum
remember um i forgot about tape yeah
okay grace what is your favorite candy
and candy bar okay my favorite candy bar
um
i'm a classics girl i'm gonna go with
snickers i love a snickers bar
especially like frozen
that could break your teeth so good you
know what's weird
you know what's weird when you're a kid
the way you look at candy versus when
you're an adult yeah like remember mr
goodbar yeah i used to think that was
like for adults i was like yeah like
that it had like rice in it like a heat
bar you know what heath bar yeah it was
like boujou
well i was like it's like that's like
the healthy
one
so funny that's how i felt about
whoppers because they kind of like i
don't know i just don't like walkers
like to me like mr goodbar was like
mature snickers that's so like an adult
sticker what about a sour patch kid do
you mess with that i love it i actually
love this because
they're not my favorite like but why do
they even make the green ones do you
listen if people are watermelon
this tournament
wouldn't they
because it's a fun tournament and you
should join us it's so much fun you're
definitely gonna be bobby lee and
santino so don't worry about that i
think we've already beat them two people
behind you already wait my favorite
candy though just just for the record is
twizzlers
i love good ones we don't talk about
twizzlers enough as a society did you
ever give them the straw yes
i drink my movie theater i drink my
coca-cola with them and then it tastes
like cherry coke okay well that's that's
why you guys
gerds rhymes with nerds love nerds no
nerds i'm not a nerds person
house a whole nerds box in one no i'm
interested in this tournament do i chew
them yeah but then but the thing is the
good thing about nerds is they get stuck
in your teeth and you can kind of lick
it like yeah kind of nerds for the rest
of the day it's a candy though if you
ever keep saying spilled nerds yes yes
ruins your day i have yep it's like
getting glitter it's a candy glow it
melts everywhere yes yes it's a bummer
apple jolly rancher wow
julie rancher that was so good
jolly ranchers did anybody like when you
were in high school you know how people
would tp people's houses did anybody
ever jolly rancher somebody's windows
that ruined windows this became a thing
in my high school and or not at my high
school but like in the area and um
like if you lick a jolly rancher and you
stick it to the window and it freezes
outside it'll break the glass yeah it's
bad kids we're like doing that for fun
and just racking up thousands of dollars
in property damage so you're a vandal i
didn't do it hashtag kansas city
i dated a guy named bubba in high school
and uh what was his name though
from what i understand it was bubba
because he used to hit his head against
the wall and he was a baby
god emily
anyway
anyway he was uh he dumped me and
we took joshua he said bubba gotta go
he said bye-bye
we took chocolate he was oh during a
football game
okay so he was playing football and he
broke out with me so we took hershey's
cereal chocolate candy hershey syrup and
just wrote my name on his windshield
you're gonna tell him who did it you're
in the crime himself dumb wait wait what
or maybe we didn't write my name we
wrote all over his windshield with
chocolate and it froze and it wouldn't
like it ruined his car which is how
probably how magic shell was invented
yeah did i imagine great idea why are
you so into vengeance
yeah here's the key the key to magic
shell is that it's like a chocolate you
pour onto ice cream and as soon as it
hits cold it like gets freezes
i feel like that was a woman who was
scorned who was doing something similar
so the lesson here for you kiddos is to
next time you get revenge on someone
write it down always go through with it
patented
it to get that copyright and get that
copied
when i was 14. okay now i'm really into
this candy
thing because i'm learning so much about
you guys um i mean i regret it but i i
still want to know like favorite uh
popsicle
from like from like a bomb pop
is that the one that you push up no no
it's the one that's fourth of july it's
like white red and blue sure so good can
i translate to flavors on top of these
my favorite is that but chocolate and
banana
what it's banana chocolate banana it's
like
neopolitan
chocolate banana chocolate we have them
in washington d.c love them with
popsicles i love them
no i love fudge clothes
oh my god i i mean you can't you eat the
creamsicles even i like the
powerpuff girl one bubbles
flintstones one remember the flintstones
push pops yeah the push pops i was just
getting very excited because in the
candy crush tournament that we're
playing that i'm playing that you're
playing for me
um
because i'm authentic
there's like an icing thing so it just
made me think about like icing i'm very
specific about like what kind of cakes i
like popsicles candy i'm gonna put it
all into the same umbrella okay but i'm
just curious like when you were a kid
and you went to the when the ice cream
truck started playing ice cream what was
your order chocolate chip cookies
vanilla sandwich uh with uh chocolate
chips on the outside chocolate chip
cookies vanilla ice cream and then it
was rolled in chocolate chips on the
outside not a klondike but it was i know
you're talking about the chocolate
chocolate chip cookie sandwich num yeah
number one like every day see i have uh
teeth uh my teeth get cold i can't eat
those well i didn't wish out i just
plowed through it's so cool you guys had
ice cream trucks because we had to go
get milk and then we had to churn the
milk for hours and hours in our ice
cream that's not a joke and we made ice
cream you you're telling us that you
lived somewhere where you couldn't go
buy ice cream i'm telling you we didn't
you chose not to there wasn't an ice
cream truck just wheeling around but
there was there was
station what were the ice creams
remember those drumstick cones yes
those are good i love those if you're
like on a road trip or and you go by any
like gas station and open up that
freezer box and there's like a pina
colada like like you know it's just all
sugar and chemicals but
do you know the little tiny cups of ice
cream that you eat with the wooden spoon
in my mouth
i'm not even an ice cream person and i
would be like i was obsessed with those
that's like a smoothie that's like an
aftertaste yeah that's just good yeah
but
as an adult have you yet picked candy to
give to trick-or-treaters no no i don't
see what would you pick i did it a
couple years ago and i'm gonna tell you
how it went
i would pick the giant bars to be like
that's the house with the giant bars got
it got it got it and so all the parents
hate you right because
oh
i know it's a big thing picking candy to
give for halloween i would give out
the reese's pumpkins obviously hershey's
bars
popcorn
just regular old hershey's and reese's
pumpkins because i mean you can't go
wrong we used to have a little lady in
pittsburgh in our neighborhood make
peanut brittle and put it in just like
saran wrap bags and passed out the first
thing my parents did when we got it home
was throwing the trash no no you know
homemade what apples had razors in it
anything homemade candy hard past yeah
we weren't even allowed just wasting
time
i was eating all the homemade things
fudge
bring it home bring it home um here's
what i will say i love that you love
candy corn candy corn is really
important toxic to me
gummy bears i love gum remember the
gummy cokes like or the waxy i was just
thinking about that where you had to
bite the wax off the top and drink it
that's definitely why you now are sick
a lot of the candies we ate growing up
were like eat this piece of wax
we would have to eat like four band-aids
i mean half of the things that i ate out
of had a toy in it you'd eat the toy
yeah remember cracker jacks i guess i
ate the toy half the time yeah so you
know because you just like are you know
we were root beer tabs that like they're
like alka they're like what are they
called yeah i know what you're talking
about but there's also the ruby or
barrels
yeah the barrels those were so those are
different though those are like hard
candy you went to a movie the other
night what did you what candy do you get
at the concession stand of the movie
twizzlers twizzlers
you're about to hear the hottest one of
all it's called scorching scorching hot
everybody get ready to sweat
i don't do uh i don't do
red twizzlers i'm a licorice person
licorice is my favorite
favorite favorite that like black
licorice black licorice i stayed in a
relationship six months longer than i
should because you both love black
licorice you're okay you just love
punishment there's a bear a band uh i
did date a guy to band that was a
mistake too but there was a brand that
has a panda on the front a licorice
brand oh no
um brand you're gonna have to like it
and it has a pan on it look at that all
natural licorice this is my favorite
thing in the world look has a little
panda it's who's that candy licorice
it's called pan licorice juice they are
so good it's such a weird bitterness i
don't like red licorice i only like
black licorice i can already tell you
that's not good i
love it i i there's you can actually
even make put it in like drinks like if
you just like drop it in um like a
sprite or something it'll be like a
licorice drink nothing that says all
natural and the biggest font is going to
be good
this is the like organization do you
ever want to ruin a sprite put a
licorice
you want people to not drink your sprite
yeah yeah yeah sprite popsicles those
are both i love licorice i'm a big
licorice person and let me ask you of
the remember the how many licks does it
take to get the center of them
i love a tootsie pop
when i was a kid but now i don't know
about
my
uh brother-in-law's nephew had a tootsie
roll when he was like three or four
okay his name's andrew all right fine
my nephew
tried a tootsie roll when he was four
hated it so much
thought it was chocolate has never had
chocolate to this day he's 12 years old
my college my freshman year college
roommate hated chocolate because he
thinks that's what chocolate tastes like
and he refuses you're just trying emily
you know what my real favorite candy is
airheads i do love
it when i was blackout you don't like
airheads when i was blackout drunk the
other day i called emily and airhead uh
sad lonely sad lonely airhead and i it
made me think of these these remember
they were just like goose yeah yeah the
white little the
but you know what else though you're
making me think of i know we're not
going into this isn't necessarily candy
and um emily's gonna lose her mind
because i'm stepping out of the
boundaries that i myself created in
terms of the candy categories
fruit roll-ups
the cherry fruit roll-ups we would wrap
them on our fingers and like
suck on them and it would like have
nails yes yes and you would get like
stuck on your fingers oh we used to use
like we would put them in like tongues
and be like i'm a lizard
like that we use it all the time
i mean me so i was giving candy out on
halloween a couple years ago i did
bags of gummy worms
okay because when you're a kid gummy
worms are a big deal that's true keep
them for a long time during worms
pudding
love yeah like because you chocolate
goes bad because the idea of halloween
candy is you can keep it so true have it
under your bed for a year yeah you know
what i'm saying i also love those you
know those black and red raspberries
that are like jelly in the middle yeah
they're kind of like they're briars i
want to say
um you've seen that i can't believe you
kept candy for a year oh yeah yeah yeah
this is why we all have different bodies
we would
i'm obviously winning this um because
grace is playing for me but uh
crushes grace you said yours emily said
your
crushes no one agreed with them but fine
yeah they were um repellent it's okay do
you have any more questions do you have
any more crushes uh benjamin i mean i
could go with the queen of england you
know because all that jewelry longevity
wow interesting yeah i want someone who
outlived me absolutely the queen of
angles and she probably will
yeah um oh i never finished why i have
such a big crush on jordan catalano oh
yes so i remember watching my so-called
life when i was a kid i feel like you
could go back and watch my so-called
life now
young people would still get it it was
so intense and so emotional and like
perfectly captured the drama of having
crushes in high school and just the
agony of being in high school
uh the vicissitudes uh of like
the
emotions you know do you know what that
show was for us what degrassi degrassi
no mine it goes there i'm telling you oh
interesting that was a canadian show
that's what drake was on yes right you
know what my social life only ran for
one season doesn't it feel shocked
doesn't it feel like it was a party one
season that is
shocking to me right and i met the guy
because it feels it feels like it was
ten years i know well the showrunner of
uh uh the nbc show i did the first
season was on that show well i met the
guy that canceled the show when i worked
at snl and i said something to him about
it like a network head yeah he was ahead
of network and would you say i said what
were you thinking why did you cancel it
what do you say and they're like stop
drinking at work don't talk to them
don't talk to the executives
and i was like roger
it um was so intense and so brilliant i
mean raeanne i
is truly one of the greatest characters
ever
and claire danes uh was just absolutely
brilliant and jared leto playing jordan
catalano there is no way this is gonna
be worth the build up
he was like kind of dumb he was like the
hell he couldn't read
okay
so he's
he's okay now i'm i'm multitasking i'm
playing candy crush while i'm talking
about my crush um
jared leto's character jordan catalano
was
hiring a tutor and the tutor was the
dork who was in love with angela who was
claire danes character but claire danes
was of course in love with jordan
catalano and so
when
the famed jordan catalano has to meet
brian the nerd
he doesn't know uh his name but uh the
brian character is wearing like a
sticker that says his name he goes
what's your name
brain cause he couldn't
he called him brain
and i laughed so hard i thought it was
so funny when i was a kid
and endearing and that began
my penchant for toxic
men that need to be rescued and taught
to read
um and that's when i started falling in
love with men that i could raise as my
own child instead of as an evil right
it's also the reason you made the movie
the female brian the female brian
i made a movie called the female brain
which brings me to my next crush uh toby
kevin
love toby kevill this to me he is the
okay so toby cable you saw him in there
was a uh in
it was called the entire history of you
was the name of the black mirror episode
that he was on the episode where your
eyeball records everything oh yeah and
you can't lie to anyone because you can
always say like where were you on july
15th right you know where we're the
other night i was hanging with my
friends well let's pull up the tape in
your head right it looks like you
cheated whatever right right right and
um
and he was incredible in that i'd only
seen him in dramas
and
i just
i can't explain it there was just
something just so attractive about him
to me
he has this crow magnum energy you know
like not that theater dork energy that a
lot of actors have
um
that's the thing about having crushes on
actors it's like it's it's all fun and
games until they're like i just booked
the role of pip and fiddle on the roof
[Applause]
um so
yeah there's i also like but the good
side of actors is they are good liars
and that is kind of refreshing because
i'd rather you be a good liar than a bad
liar just at least sell it so toby
kebbel is the reason that i did not
quit that movie
a week before i
wanted to
tell me i had such a crush on him
and he
talked to me like he would like talk to
me on set he also by the way
in english uh an incredibly i mean a
devastating english accent yeah and he
played a i think he was from boston in
the movie
and he showed up on set and spoke and
just nailed the accent but like on set
the whole time so he i'd only heard him
speak in his english accent and he
showed up and he's like hey what's up
yeah like he's doing his american accent
my pants yeah he like
so handsome and i had such a crush on
isn't he just the most yeah i would get
up and dry my hair to come to work which
i had not done in like two years because
i was like i could get this guy but
i didn't
so weird how you're wrong
this is when emily was uh on the set of
the female brian uh
also she was brian sometimes known as
the female brain which is um on hulu i
believe now it is it was on airplanes
delta flights everywhere still on
airplanes emily was had been my
assistant for a couple years three years
and she had had it
those jobs have a shelf life those jobs
have a shelf like i had tried to let you
go numerous times and you wouldn't you
had asked me specifically to leave i
said you're overqualified
you did try to promote me i just was
sticking around too long you just
couldn't i couldn't leave and then
you all i remember is seeing you on set
with a
fan like a little mini fan it was it was
july it was we were in the in santa
clarita it was me and a one beanie
feldstein
in we're wearing suits like i'm wearing
an oxford shirt and a suit and a bun and
we're doing a scene outside it was like
a record high i believe two days after
we left that location it caught fire
like
actually we had a continuity issue
because it caught on fire
because of just from the heat it just
literally burst into flames and this by
the way the same place we shot the uh
the good people pilot that same uh same
college campus i was there for that too
traumatized oh yeah that's why i met you
yes and then em i look over and emily
has a little portable fan in her hand
and she's like checking emails
like like sending her resume to other
people
and she's the only person with a fan on
the set i am sweating profusely
uh i brought my own emily what broke you
when i asked you to pick me up no i it
was by the airport
i just remember you were crying in a g
wagon yes your g-wagon yes um that was a
very stressful time i i get it now you
had you were and you were very
frustrated that we were very it was
amazing i had hired my
my other best friend nick that was the
price
so but were you guys playing this game
this tournament because it's super fun
you know what if i had candy crush on
the set of the female brain and i could
have used it you know what a healthy
outlet to just yes
that instead of texting me i quit i quit
i hate you i'm gonna sue you and this is
how much i want for my settlement right
right right right right like playing
crushing candies yeah to be but on the
set of movies the good news is that
craft services the lower the budget is
the more candy you get yes
not food it's just candy right they're
trying to distract you they are i have
had more
candy uh on my in on in my time making
movies uh
malt balls so malt balls
is probably my number one favorite
flavor like a mulch like a whopper
whopper malt balls they come in like
yeah like a milk carton yeah i love it
yeah well okay wow it's all coming
together
but my dad loves those daddy
um i love malt balls okay so really
quick toby kevill what else um
and like can you invite him over here
sometime
he's got a child
um if it'll make you blow dry your hair
yeah
uh brad goldstein
one of my biggest crushes is the one
brett goldstein
and my roommates are famously obsessed
with him really fast i swear famously
famously in my world
just famously so this is wild because
emily and i uh we did a pilot for hbo
and i when when you're making television
you and you're casting a boyfriend
you're kind of just shopping for a
boyfriend we had a great time you're
hiring someone that you're actually
attracted to that your character
is in love with it right it's very hard
to keep things professional i'm a real
actor i'm a method actor i get lost in
my character yeah i'm like i just
so brad colstein came in this was before
ted lasso and i was instantly just like
submitting with him and i'm like ah i'm
just such a good producer look at me
just hiring the best actor he did happen
to be the best actor and
i just fell in love with him on every
level i have a surprise for you you
ready
whoa hey buddy
hey
hey how are you
whose dog is this technically it belongs
to some tulle but uh
i adopted her
you adopted a dog
that's not what i'm saying that's
exactly what you just said okay
she was in a really bad situation she
was suffocating in a car and you know so
i i had to do something
mandy
we can't have a dog
why not
because when a couple decide to have a
dog they discuss it first because it's a
big deal it's like having a kid or
something okay well that sounds like
something my aunt would tweet so brett
was when the show wrapped after the set
after the he plays the soccer player on
ted lasso right yeah he won the set and
on your show he played a wallpaper
designer
can i tell you it is i loved that it's
so tender i'm obsessed with jobs in tv
shows and movies and i work really hard
to make sure the jobs are always super
specific and not just like magazine
editor like advertising person there's
someone that i was like he's an artist
but he has to be somewhat successful
right if you're like a painter or a
designer
the big success would be you design a
wallpaper and it like gets in a hotel or
it becomes like one of those like ellie
cashman wallpaper like yeah a big
instagram wallpaper that does like an
accent bathroom or something and they
loved it and that's what but so after
the show arrived and we had got we were
all buddies and he was going he was
going back to london and i was gonna do
like a three week john in london because
i had a pretty flexible vacation policy
back then
because you would be quick because it
wasn't a vacation
policy you would just quit and then come
back whenever you wanted hbo kept paying
me and you were like okay so
i went and went to
england for three weeks and brett was
there and when you found out that brett
was gonna be there and i was on my
holiday you were like well i'm gonna
come too
and we were like okay but who's gonna
book your ticket and you were like you
took it and i was like i can't just
gonna fuck your dick
i'm coming there how do i get there
someone how are you
where's kayak where's kayaks
alexa flip trips flip trips trip drops
hop stop hopscotch stops
value jet
anyway we didn't end up hanging out so
don't worry
thank god can i tell you speaking of
candy crush in this tournament that
we're playing in
english candy is totally different oh
wow oh yeah have you ever had this too
arrow bar an aero bar is like puffed
rice krispies in so
good oh god my favorite so i do think if
you don't like the same kind of candy
someone else likes you can't be in a
relationship with them oh i disagree
because then you each have your own
candy yeah yeah i don't need you like
anything i like but me really i don't
even need you like me that's true
don't worry
i don't know
that's why she's gonna work with chris
evan she's like you don't have to like
me you know what i don't candies i don't
like i do not like candy necklaces oh no
what i can't stand them that's fake
they're fun though wearable candy gross
it's just it stresses me i like the
candy engagement ring that you're
wearing now i don't like like like look
at me eating my king and then i'm going
to put on my neck my triple what about
candy bracelets no you're like i'm sober
anklet that is gross
a candy toe ring oh can you tell ring
there's a there's somebody out there for
that what is the most popular candy i've
had m m's really yeah that's a good
guess they have commercials
what is the most popular candy this is
kind of most popular candy in the world
snickers
i've never even opened one i'm so afraid
of products in hotel rooms and how much
they cost you know we slept on what twix
why not
because they have gluten there's no
gluten gluten-free twix nope
what's that what about the left one
yeah
there's different you know there's right
twists and left legs oh
yeah you're right no they're both
they are good though
they also have gluten i don't like cake
cups remember crunch bars oh yes
i love bunch of crunch that's my movie
crunchiness me too bungee creams are
great my favorite
crunchy bars is candy for kids is the
best selling candy in the u.s
have you ever been to hershey park in
pennsylvania i smell it from the parking
lot that's pretty the chocolate pretty
amazing
i've ever been to eminem's world in nyc
don't go
what oh yeah in
time there's a ferris wheel
my favorite set of sex tuplets was born
in hershey pennsylvania outside the
hotel that was
you just ruined my day
your favorite set how many are like
the goslings
um for my 23rd birthday my family made
me a cake of the goslings and then put
my head over the oldest daughter's head
because she was my favorite i
photoshopped my myself into a picture of
the gosselin when i was in middle school
i said johnny plus ton did you know that
according to news the average chocolate
bar contains eight insect parts
that's protein that is three proteins
why are you ruining like why anything
less than 60 insect pieces per 100 grams
of chocolate is deemed safe for
consumption yeah the food and drug
medication
when i found out that their eyelashes
all over your bugs all over your
eyelashes like whoever found that out
should have kept it to themselves
about that
wait what about our duke are klondike
bars candy no that's ice cream no that's
ice cream uh the fda officially allows
up to 60 insect fragments per 100 grams
of chocolate and it doesn't end there
insect pieces can be found in almost
everything we consume maraschino
cherries are made from beetlejuice
from coffee to cinnamon with the result
that we naturally consume quite a large
quantity of bugs over the course of a
year good yeah that's okay with me i'm
okay i mean look
i don't have to see him
uh people with chocolate allergies may
experience a variety of symptoms how do
you know when you've hit your quota like
i want to know when i'm done eating bugs
for the year
i mean think about the dead skin we're
bringing in all the kids you're so right
yeah we eat a lot of dead skin
my own i'm not if it's my own no it's us
in the room with you they say that's why
you develop personality traits of other
people because you're breathing in their
dna no
we need gas masks in here
[Laughter]
forever no wonder we all suddenly have
tourette's uh now i'm just winning i
feel like we have to get for sure i
might be getting you in the fridge
flavor
peach
jelly whoa okay you like the peach rings
too oh i like the spicy ones sometimes i
get real crazy and and i'll eat a
popcorn jelly bean
yeah what's the point
just you know i want to feel alive it's
amazing how they can make it taste just
like popcorn jelly means they used to
have on the back
they would have a way to mix them like
if you mix the peanut butter one it was
like cherry yeah it's like peanut butter
and jelly like like cherry and coke it
was like cherry cola totally yeah i used
to do that but but prickly pear is
number one my
do favorite love chocolate covered
cherries which is weird because now we
have prickly pear margherita ginger
that's true that is weird wait i thought
that's why you had pregnancy no no
she's like i love princesses put it
together the brand is so strong that it
i thought that's why that was just that
authentic no i just realized that that
is so
crazy just put it together that's like
me getting a pet panda and being like i
knew it i yeah like i did not make the
connection until just now i manifested
it by accident crazy yeah that is wild
chocolate covered cherries
williams and sonoma yes they do use does
bags of chocolate covered blueberries
chocolate covered cherries
berries that they sell in the bags from
costco do you guys know what i'm talking
about those are a little bitter to me
yeah they're kind of boring a little
bitter chocolate covered banana chips
yes
yeah totally yes please chocolate
covered potato chips fight me oh i've
never had one there's what so good
they're so good they're sweet and salty
candy uh yes i used to when i was a kid
it's shrek's favorite but i don't know
the rest of us like it i like it it's
fun it's like a what it's gone you're
gonna get it twice a year
i'm not gonna get it at all grace okay
so who's winning this tournament because
because we have some high schools
i'm not i think
millions and millions of points okay so
i'm on level 58. what am i on what who's
like okay let's stop playing the
tournament right now okay you guys don't
need to stop playing the tournament yeah
you can never stop can go play the
tournament is free to enter you just
need to be on level 26 to compete the
final winner will receive a year's
supply of gold bars
to use in the game enter the all-star
competition for a chance to
win be a winner don't be a loser i would
date someone with access to
a couple hundred questions i'm so funny
what i did like like on your dating
profile don't even swipe right unless
you have access to gold bars honestly
not real goals like i'm a gold digger
but not money honestly you could have
just said i would date someone now we
have to get to the the
cause santino andrew santino and bobby
lee
uh did this also and i just want to make
sure if we beat them i'm happy right
honestly
but so what is it because now let's wrap
up our tournament within us because
whoever
wins
or whoever loses has to eat the beans
right mm-hmm and whoever wins what what
does this what do you get if you win oh
you would break i mean i don't really i
don't i don't text you on the beginning
how about you lose your job whoever wins
i'm 11 p.m to 7 a.m that's your time
that's your time
whoever wins you get the will
whoever wins gets to not hear from me
for one weekend
um no the win the win is the street cred
of winning our tournament and winning
candy crush
how about this whoever wins gets to keep
these candy crush dresses yes
real conversations i hope i win because
i'll need all three
we are now
pencils are down phones are down candy
crush is down and we are now going to
reveal our scores and who the winners
and the losers really are ben tim what's
your score mine is 874 060. rude mine's
thousand seventy four hundred and sixty
one what what him only 174 thousand it's
whatever pensions was plus one
okay what's mine uh uh grace
10.
okay i was talking because i was trying
to make sure we get to our crushes and
talk about candy well
what is yours grace
100 000 i'm the loser of this game and
in general you know what real winners
lose
every now and then because guess what
who's got the single shot
i'm in it who's the winner who's the
winner
you're not in a single room
screen time wise losing is the new
winning this guy that's true
we've got two thumbs in one okay this
actually is my nightmare because these
are candies that
they may all look the same but they are
not the same some are delicious
and some are
just gonna make yeah me gag so
ugh okay what color first okay this this
is this jelly bean is either a toasted
marshmallow oh
or a stink bug oh stinky
[Music]
you know you know what if it's not that
you don't need to do that in my family
this is gonna trigger yourself
you said they may all look the same but
they're not like a ryan murphy movie
show
no
okay i didn't get that far
in that was definitely i can't smell it
that was stink bug oh god i can smell it
the key to stink bug is when you're done
with it you have to put it away
oh
and now we can usually see the june
shine i know i see that now
you have to pop oh no oh you took us oh
my gosh you're gonna you know what's so
sad what you're gonna go to this concert
and talk to people with that breath i'm
gonna go to the latest morissette
concert and stink bug all over everyone
but here now the two jelly beans i've
been handed are either okay
baby wipes yep toothpaste or
berry blue berry blue so it's a little
either way it's gonna be a win-win yeah
because i do need toothpaste after that
okay um
raspberry blue okay oh god that is
delicious
and this is you're gonna mix them
questions stink bugs i can smell it i
can't we got it too i got it i'm
stretching you out okay one more one
more one more let's do a i don't know uh
i do not want to eat canned dog food oh
i want you to do the vomit don't do that
i don't i'm good on bombing he's going
to vomit on her i've tasted vomit a
couple times now right do the dish the
dishwasher oh yeah the dishwasher is
going to be ooh ooh do that one dirty
dishwasher or birthday cake just raw
milk there's so many white ones this one
okay this white one is either spoiled
milk or coconut honestly i think small
milk is better than coconut oh wow
that's wrong so funny
okay okay
okay well i lost i lost i think we can
all agree that
you know that one too i
do believe that um
emily you should sign us out because i'm
gonna go peek
all right guys make sure that you sign
up and play in the most amazing candy
crush tournament
let me oh
it is the best tournament it's so fun we
had so much fun playing we had so much
fun listening to whitney and grace and
emily and also i talked to some and it
was really really fun and cute and you
should join the tournament
because you won't regret it you won't
regret it should we do something where
we give away these these dresses
let's make sure we mock them sure if you
you want one of these dresses
i'm not giving mine away
us at our candy crush dresses how cute
are we
we talked about candy we talked about
our crushes we played candy crush the
tournament i'm telling you candy crush
is the way
to not text your exes get your fingers
to do something productive and fun for
one distract yourself from the nightmare
that is the news that is your emails it
is your text thank you
thank you candy crush for being that
soothing balm
that gets me through tsa
it's so funny thank you candy crush we
love you thanks jamie
candy crush on you are you gonna say
that i was gonna say it but you say it
we have a candy crush on you on you
candy crush
bye
i'm gonna go don't ride jelly beans
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]